ah chic a go a Chicago Chicago I'm sorry
I can't pronounce stuff my name is Emma
laser let's get to it the area of
today's Chicago is inhabited by the
alcone coin people of Miami and Muscat
and tribes the name Chicago came from
the French explorers interpretation of a
Miami Illinois word shakakwa or cheek
Akua meaning wild garlic which according
to the French explorers Gurion and
abundance on the south end of Lake
Michigan the Chicago Board edge which
forms a water connection from the Great
Lakes to the Mississippi River system
attracted the attention of many French
traders who brought to be betrayed to
the Chicago area effectively making a
strategically important area of the 17th
century beaver wars after the beaver
wars most of the all-conquering tribes
were driven out of the area by the
Iroquois which in turn left the area
after the non-fun treaty in the 1920s
during this time other tribes like oh
gee whiz and potawatomi's tried to
settle the area but there are no signs
of any permanent settlements by them the
French also tried to colonize the area
but eventually they were driven out by
the Native American rates during the Fox
Wars first old-world settler in Chicago
was Jean Baptiste point recipient who
built a farm at the mouth of the Chicago
River by the year 1788 in 1795 after the
Northwest Indian War USA finally gained
more authority over the area and to
assert its claims for Dearborn on the
Chicago River
sadly the fort was destroyed in the war
of 1812 and many of the inhabitants were
killed or taken prisoner by the Native
American tribes however after the war
the Fort Dearborn was rebuilt in 1818 to
again assert the u.s. claim over the
area and deter any raids by the Native
Americans in the year 1829 the area of
today's Chicago had feared an hundred
inhabitants most of which were soldiers
serving in the Fort Dearborn but
interestingly enough there was a one
legal tavern in the area at the time
owned by Archibald Caldwell who was most
certainly the first landlord with a
tavern and Chicago a year later fourth
of August 1830 the plight of Chicago was
charted and this is seen as the first
official recognition of an area called
Chicago after its official recognition
many new england enterpreneurs started
to pour money into the area's
development as they saw the potential of
Chicago becoming a transportation hub
three years later a town of Chicago was
founded with a population of around 350
people and in the next
seven years the number will increase by
whole 12 folds during which Chicago is
granted city status by the state of
Illinois
even though Chicago's population has
started to increase much of its wealth
still came from farming it wasn't until
the 1848 opening of the Illinois
Michigan Canal which allows shipping
from the Great Lakes through Chicago to
the mississippi river and the gulf of
mexico that chicago started to grow as a
trading hub later this was reinforced by
the 1850s construction of railroads
which helped solidify Chicago's claim as
one of the most important trading hubs
in the USA over 30 railway lines entered
the city with the main lines from East
ending in Chicago and the main lines
heading west beginning in Chicago by the
1860s the city became the nation's
transshipment hub and warehousing center
with so many materials flowing through
the city it makes only sense that a
large number of factories sprang up
during the 1850s and 60s with the sudden
industrialization the city also
underwent a huge expansion in population
going from a little above 4,000 people
in 1840 to 30,000 people in 1850 and
hundred and twenty-two thousand people
in 1860 however this sudden spike in
population and industrialization
combined with the fact that Chicago is
almost the same elevation as Lake
Michigan created a little or no
naturally-occurring drainage because of
this many travelers to Chicago reported
it as the filthiest city in America plus
the standing water harbored pathogens
and cost numerous epidemics this forced
the city to take the drainage problem
seriously and started a huge project of
putting down sewer pipes and then
lifting parts of the city over them in
one instance an entire acre of masonry
rows of shops and offices were lifted
four feet eight inches over the course
of five days during this time all of the
businesses were still open people came
when shopped and worked in them as if it
was an ordinary day this tremendous
undertaking of putting down the sewer
system and lifting of the city helped
drastically with the outbreak of
epidemics and the city could once again
function to its full capacity
going into the 1870s things seemed great
the city was booming with large
factories being built to refine the huge
portions of goods flowing through the
city's training helps working in the
vastly growing sector where large
numbers of German and Irish
immigrants looking for a better future
unfortunately in 1871 the Great Chicago
Fire struck no one knows how the fire
started but when it did it spread like
wildfire consuming much of central
Chicago burning for three days straight
but it was finally contained one third
of the city's 300,000 inhabitants were
homeless and 300 of them were dead now
with much of the city center in ruins
Chicago decided to pivot replacing the
former wooden structures with brick and
masonry a first building these
structures was a problem as the soft
swampy ground near the lake proved
unstable for tall masonry buildings but
the builders developed a new innovation
of still framing the supports of a
building effectively creating the basis
for the modern skyscraper in fact it was
in Chicago that the first modern
definition of a skyscraper was built in
1884 sadly the building was demolished
in 1931 but similar buildings from that
time period still stand in Chicago today
now rebuilt from the great fire and
going into the 20th century Chicago got
another major influx of immigrants this
time mostly Jewish and Western Slavic
people and also sizable numbers of Greek
and Italians putting the city's
population well over 2 million people
before World War one after World War 1
however the migration slowed down and
almost stopped as new government
immigration laws were passed making it
harder for Eastern Europeans to come
into the country during the Prohibition
era the city became a playing ground for
mobsters that gain money and influence
through the control of the city's
illegal alcohol trade Howard the roaring
20s wouldn't last
and with the hit of the Great Depression
Chicago just as any other city in USA
struggled to keep afloat nonetheless
thanks to the post-world War Two economy
boom Chicago is back on track expanding
its trading hubs and industry but was
the lack of cheap labor from Europe due
to immigration laws Chicago gained a
large influx of African American workers
from the south which in 1990s made up
almost 40% of the city's population
Chicago today is part of the Rust Belt
with its industry shifting from
unskilled physical labor to more skilled
finance marketing computer addict abased
labor this creates lots of new skilled
jobs in the city but also excludes the
large population of unskilled workers
which are forced to leave the city to
find jobs elsewhere however unlike other
Rust Belt cities Chicago has managed to
make this transition quite successfully
even be
named by GQ as the city of the year in
2008 Chicago as a city is a great
example of the American historical city
building scene the fact that a city can
be founded in the same century that its
population reaches a million is
astounding it shows us the economically
strategical importance of the Chicago
area and the willingness of millions of
migrants to leave their homes for a
better life in the Windy City
[Music]